[Music]
growing outrage over a reported plan to
give cold hard cash to illegal border
crossers according to the wall street
journal the biden administration is in
talks to pay up to a billion dollars to
illegal immigrant families separated at
the border under former president
trump's zero tolerance policy with each
person set to get a payout of up to 450
thousand dollars republicans say
that plan cannot move forward
first you break the law you get amnesty
with democrats now they're going to pay
you for breaking the law i mean you you
think we have a problem in a caravan
coming towards towards the border now
and what we've seen over the last
several months wait until the word gets
out that you actually get paid for
breaking the law to come into our
country
this incomprehensibly
uh stupid idea of passing out up to a
half a million dollars
to people whose first act in this
country
was a violation of our law makes no
sense at all that is going to be a slap
in the face to every hard-working
american who works hard and plays by the
rules and it will especially be in a
slap in the face uh to people that have
immigrated legally to this country
congressman dan crenshaw tweeting for
perspective if a service member is
killed in action their next of kin gets
an insurance payment of 400 thousand
dollars
let that sink in
and dozens of house republicans just
sent a letter to three cabinet
secretaries behind the reported plan
demanding answers
jesse i'm guessing because you brought
this up yesterday we weren't sure if it
was the babylon view or if it was real
yeah
it's realistic
policy is written by the babylon bee he
pays you to break the law
and then he bails you out remember if
you break the law and uh didn't he also
stop building the border wall and then
build the border wall around his own
house
and then he he put the kids in cages the
same cages that he got mad at trump for
putting people in those happened to be
the same cages he built when he was the
vp
and
so i think he spies on your bank account
if you haven't broken the law
puts a half a million in your bank
account for breaking the law and then he
fires you from work and then pays you
not to work
and then he flies illegals into new york
in the dead of night and said it's
actually not the dead of the night it's
actually early in the morning
oh my god this guy's already shattered
the all-time american record for illegal
entries and then he blamed trump for
that now there was a reason we all
remember why we had to separate families
because donald trump was following the
letter of the law you cannot hold adults
and minors in the same facility legally
and you can't hold minors for more than
21 days plus you had to separate them to
see if they were actually parents or if
these were kids just getting traffic and
it did have a very strong deterrent
effect
do you remember when there was a guy who
came into the country i think it was
like 11 times illegally and then
murdered an american woman in a
sanctuary city kate steinle she sued san
francisco and the federal government for
damages
and the federal government wouldn't pay
her they said no but they're going to
pay an illegal to come over here we've
been separated from our families we were
told we couldn't see our grandparents we
couldn't see our parents we couldn't
visit them in a nursing home we couldn't
say goodbye to them on their death beds
couldn't hold a funeral couldn't go see
him in church
what did we get a check for two thousand
dollars and these people come in here
and they get a half a mil
this is crazy this is crazy and now it's
time for commercial break no i'm just
kidding uh jessica this is gonna be
really tough messaging if the
administration stands by this i'm just
putting it out there i do not want this
to be the lead message for the midterm
elections
no definitely not um
we'll see if it comes to pass a lot of
these things are proposals that exist
and they never actually come to fruition
and everybody gets hot and bothered
about it as we just heard and then
nothing happens but it is important just
to say
that we had you know 5 000 sets of
parents or guardians whoever whether
they were actually related to these kids
or not separated from them and there are
still a thousand kids that we have not
reunited them with their families and
that's something that sparked outrage on
both sides of the aisle no one wants
that situation
and i believe there are 940 plaintiffs
in total for these suits and the aclu
that's part of the lawsuit has made it
clear that it's only going to be on a
minority of the 940 that would even get
any kind of settlement now i'm not
saying that i think that it's smart to
go ahead with this even particularly at
this moment where we're exceptionally
vulnerable anyway but this isn't like
thousands and thousands of people
getting a half a million dollar check
well it's reparations well okay but a
lot of people don't think reparations
are bad things it's not reparations
we've been told that the border is
closed but there will be those who argue
this is going to be further incentive
because in these cases where they say
there's a parent and a child that's now
up to close to a million dollars per
family i mean this is a very dangerous
journey these people embark on it's
almost like we're putting them in like
the most dangerous game show ever mm-hmm
who are you talking to people oh you
greg junior bad greg who wants to answer
do you want him it's halloween i
couldn't get a sitter
all right so here's the deal the whole
key is sorry guy
um
you cannot allow this to be framed as
democrat versus republican you cannot
allow this to be framed as an
immigration question and you cannot let
this be framed about separation this has
nothing to do at all with immigration so
you don't want to get dragged down that
hole this is about draining the power of
america which is which is because this
is so far left there's a reason behind
this if illegals get a half a million
per per illegal
we are done because that means we you
they can keep doing this and keep doing
this and this is how you drain a country
you're basically opening up the drink
you're opening us turning on the faucet
everything goes out so the only solution
is
for us
americans to sue the government we have
to start suing the government over the
perceived mistreatment of a democratic
white house or let's talk about the
afghanistan debacle surely there could
be lawsuits over that let's talk about
the response to the riots right we can
sue the the democrat cities how about
inflation how about the separation that
you brought up there are people who who
lost uh their their loved ones who
didn't even weren't they on those last
moments yeah they weren't they were the
last moment you that is way way worse
than any of this crap and a lot of this
is crap because a lot of people were
they were separated for the children's
own good and we can't forget that but
this is a bigger story about dismantling
america this is not about immigration
because this is this craziest idea it it
it goes beyond that i thought it was a
joke you were you were watching
yesterday reading it off twitter and i'm
going this that can't be right this
sounds like something that you would get
on a far right website that you would
have to check a hundred times to see
this is like ad libs for liberalism how
about wall street journal so katie you
know are we incentivizing something
that's incredibly dangerous for these
people because
what is the message then why wouldn't
you if you were in a desperate situation
whether it's economic or whatever
persecution situation that you have
coming here why wouldn't you if you hear
about this because already you know all
of our reporters who are down there
talking to these caravans that people
say we're coming because joe biden told
us to come that's their misperception of
what's going on you're incentivizing an
already multi-billion dollar criminal
cartel
industry and the body administration has
done this on multiple levels you know
flying kids in the middle of the night
to whoever they say are their relatives
in the united states they have no
interest they've taken away every single
tool we have to disincentivize to
distance to as a disincentive not to
break the law to come here illegally and
it's because joe biden said on the
campaign trail that we can absorb two
million new people a year we're almost
to that number now they believe in this
but on the issue of the separation and
paying
people families uh who were separated
the first thing i would say is it's it's
a result a reflection of how the left
feels about the american citizen right
so if you're an american citizen and you
commit a crime you were separated from
your family and sometimes for a very
long time and sometimes they put you in
prison there is no money for that and
there shouldn't be but this idea that
people who break immigration law come
into the country illegally breaking
federal law get a huge check of 450 000
to do so nobody else gets to do that if
you're a citizen the other thing is
there are tens of thousands of
unaccompanied minors who are voluntarily
separated from their parents in el
salvador in guatemala and they were sent
alone on this journey and they were
already separated and so this is just
you know it's it's a way to as greg said
drain the system but it's also a
reflection of the disdain that the left
has for the american taxpayer and how
they think that you should be paying for
rule breakers not just in the inside the
united states but coming into the
country as well how do illegals have
standing to sue and reap all these
damages they don't have standing well it
is their con
it is their right legally they are
allowed to seek asylum here that is part
of our system and so
but how do they have standing for
damages
but if they say that they're here and
they're being held against their will in
a situation that is less than ideal
they're going to be able to sue over
conditions and they have a number of
lawyers have
organized
i mean so the out so gitmo detainees
consume well they've been convicted
and a lot of they're waiting they're
waiting not all of them but they but
they didn't but there's no justification
we haven't paid and wait
they did not fight their way into
getting to gitmo you don't know what i'm
saying well they fought their way up
western is not about separation this is
about something completely different